nikolai works for philips and
for those zooming in from elsewhere
philips is a company
that has been very important to the
history of eindhoven
he's also assistant professor at the
university here
at the ue and he will be telling us
about
doing less for mri scans so
please nikolai the floor is all yours
okay
thank you so much for the introduction
and in this talk i want to
give guide you through the work that we
that we have done in the in the first
samurai challenge
which was aimed at accelerating mri
scans
so the talk will be divided in two parts
first i want to give you let's say kind
of a general
overview of ai uh
i guess i've seen uh several talks on
that
so i will not dive too deep but i just
want to give you
a flavor of how chem means in healthcare
and after that i will
talk about the first mri challenge and
present sorry present the work done with
the
phillips and lumc team that actually won
the first samurai challenge
so you already introduced me
and just this is roughly about myself so
i'm a computer scientist by train
i had experience in the startup board
working on 3d scanners
i did my phd here in the netherlands in
delft
working on the analysis of very very
large
high dimensional data as part of that i
also
worked at google ai on the analysis of
deep learning models
and also at the india the research
institute for computer science in france
and now i'm a senior scientist in
phillips and also assistant professor at
qe
part time um so maybe just one thing
about philips so
you may know phillips for the light
bulbs or
or the tvs actually the company in the
last uh
decade is actually transitioning to be a
leader in the healthcare
domain so really focus company on
uh supporting a healthcare application
and that's
of course that's one well what i'm gonna
talk uh
about today then
another a real
bird eye view on artificial intelligence
so we hear a lot about artificial
intelligence these days and it actually
is nowadays covering
uh so much uh basically also advanced
algorithms are called our artificial
intelligence
what i'm going to talk about is machine
learning which is a
subset of artificial intelligence
technology
that's really learn from data
some specific functionality so
really data-driven learning which is
actually quite fitting for
for today by the way and within this
uh as a superset of techniques
i'm going to talk about deep learning uh
which
basically is one of these groundbreaking
innovation of the let's say last decade
where basically the machine learning
technologies that
are learning from the data where are
pushed to the to the limit by
uh learning very rich representation now
this is kind of the overview that you
often see what i'm actually gonna talk
about
and i'm gonna present one of them is
let's say a niche that is not really
uh well known is actually starting let's
say from uh
uh yeah it's two years that are actually
kind of uh becoming more and more viable
and those are the uh some sort of hybrid
models
and hybrid models uh in cork incorporate
deep learning solution with
uh let's say you can say more um
traditional computations that may be
physically informed models
or other kind of uh traditional
computations to really
take out the max possible value from
deep learning
okay so that's kind of to to paint the
landscape
um now about artificial intelligence
in the healthcare domain so
in 2016 end of 2016 there was kind of a
fuss
when uh one of the let's say the
founding fathers of the modern deep
learning revolution
uh jeffrey intern actually said
i think that you if you work as a
radiologist you are
like a willy coyote in the cartoon
you are already over the edge of the
cliff but you haven't yet looked down
there's no ground beneath underneath
people should stop
training radiologists now it's just
completely obvious that in five years
deep learning is gonna do better than
radiologists
now that actually i mean we are in
at the end of uh 2020 that we don't see
that
and also other people are said that that
just
ai will do everything that's really not
happening
and uh what we see instead
is that there's a probably a better
quote
is will ai replace radiologists the
answer is no
that's that's not happening and this is
not gonna happen
but radiologists that use ai will
replace those that
don't because we see really ai as a way
to
empower uh people uh that are already
working
on in the radiology department to just
do better job better
in healthcare we have also a
burnout problem so they have a lot of
work to do
and they are focusing on stuff that is
not really important
like a compiling report and so on and in
that case
uh ai can help okay
so this is kind of again overview we see
a lot of value
on the eye especially in the radiology
department
which is basically uh as i was showing
here really the
radiologist looking at the images
looking at the
uh at the final uh the final outcome
which is actually obtained by
the scanners uh medical imaging
devices and actually this is what i'm
gonna focus today
um i'm gonna focus
on how ai can be used before
an image is actually shown to the
radiologist
and how ai can boost or and improve the
performance of these systems
and i have seen you are at the the the
conference is uh held at sml i know that
also isml is working on that
and and we see a lot of potential
actually in
boosting uh the the performance by
applying
uh machine learning models and deep
learning models in particular
all right among these
imaging modalities uh you can see here
there are mri ct x-ray
scanners i'm going to focus to a
specific one
and that's the magnetic magnetic
resonance imaging
or mri uh you see a scanner here on the
left
it's one of the very nice imaging
modalities because
it has very nice properties so first it
does not
have harmful radiation for the patient
so it's very nice you can take as many
uh mri in your lifetime without any
having any issues compared for example
to x-rays
and moreover compared to the other
modalities also has a very nice
uh definition of the images so you can
really see also the
the soft tissue that usually you cannot
see in an x-ray
now there are some problems though and
the problems are related to the
to the length of the exam uh that means
that
the compared to an x-ray that takes a
few seconds maximum
few minutes and mr scan
can exam can take up to one hour and as
you can see on the image on the left is
not the most comfortable experience you
are in a
in a very small uh setting in a very
uncomfortable uncomfortable position
and it's also extremely noisy it's crazy
noise in there so
um yeah any way that can reduce the
examination can
can be very very helpful especially
because if the patient move
uh there is most there is the most
likely we have to retake the exam
so yeah that's kind of the setting and
of course there are
have been a lot of technologies that
try to accelerate mr and
in the last 20 years but we know that
ai will play a role here and that's also
demonstrated by the fact that
uh two years ago a collaboration between
nyu langone health and facebook ai
research
they released the first and large-scale
data set
of mr images together with the raw data
what the scanner acquired
in order to accelerate the innovation
there and
yeah so they basically released that and
they asked the community please
create the best possible algorithms uh
innovating this domain and actually to
make it uh
even more compelling to work on that
they organized
the first uh first mri challenge so
they took some the raw data you can see
it here on the on the top left i'm not
going to the details i'll talk a bit
more
later they kept that and also the
corresponding images
then they released a version where the
raw data
was actually subsampled so they don't
didn't release everything
that means that you cannot directly
reconstruct the images you will have
some
artifacts and they ask the participants
to develop an algorithm that can do this
reconstruction
and provide the reconstruction back to
the organizers
and then a panel of radiologists was
looking at the difference
and evaluating them based on the on the
diagnostic quality
or the presence of artifacts really by
looking at the images
and based on that they they decided the
winner
uh of the challenge really based on the
observation that the
the value that can bring to the to the
to the practice
now uh we participated as phillips with
two teams
one a collaboration between phillips and
lmc
another one between a collaboration
between phillips and
several institutions based in amsterdam
so that that was pretty pretty exciting
to work in such a
high profile
initiative the most
exciting thing was actually that we won
all the challenge tracks
so one of the team won the the the
single call
let's say is one that is a slightly
easier
task and and one the multi-coil that
actually
really mimics the uh the the scanner
behavior
so we had actually a very nice uh
exposure to the
to our uh sea level management
uh we presented at the top ai conference
our solution
uh which is a new ribs and also i would
like to mention that
actually we competed directly against uh
competitors like uh
other companies like united imaging and
hyperfine as well as
world leading research labs so that's
that's
already i'm already telling you the
outcome of the challenge
now i want to go a bit more technical so
otherwise i'm just
talking too much high level and i i want
to inspire you a bit on this
topic of hybrid models describing a bit
more in details the
uh the the model developed with the in
the philips and lmc team
uh and a bit on the model design how we
trained
and the outcome so in order to do so
let's really have a closer look at
uh how the reconstructions are performed
so
in mr we acquire something that is
called k-space
and it looks like that so it's really
you can see them as a
radio frequency signals that are coming
from the device
and in the the most easy the easiest way
to think about it is that it's just an
inverse fourier transform
sorry for the fourier domain of your
image
it's way more complicated than that but
yeah
it's kind of give you the the right
mindset if you think about it like this
and um so that means again if you have
the k space you do an inverse fourier
transform and you get your image out
as i said before in order to accelerate
mr you basically what you do
is not to accelerate the acquisition of
the k space because there is a physical
and physiological limits to that what
you do
you acquire less and basically you only
acquire the lines
on this sampling mask so you acquire
less data
but the problem is that if you do that
uh
you have the and you just do the inverse
fourier transform
you get the image on the right so the
one with uh with a lot of artifacts
so the the solution is actually to to
have these
hybrid ai or hybrid algorithms
to actually go back to to the true
reconstruction
so again we cannot just accelerate
hardware with the hardware so we reach
the limit there we cannot
go beyond that due to the physical
properties of the acquisition system
and we need to use software to
to boost it and so what we did we
developed the
adaptive compress cs network
that is a deep learning solution that
integrates
uh elements of the compressed sensing
theory
i will try to give you an idea of what
is about
but again we integrate deep learning
with traditional computations
and what is compressed sensing
compressed sensing is a is a technique
intro
introduced uh 15 years ago uh
it works like that it's a iterative
algorithm so that means that you don't
have just
the the bad image and the and the final
image at the end
you have uh you actually you improve the
image
uh iteratively so you have a lot of
intermediate steps in this case you
only see one and what you do you
basically take your uh your image
you apply some function uh which is
called a sparse defined transform
in this case it's this f then
uh in this domain uh you see this in
iteration and you see
um what it looks like
in this case it's a wavelength
decomposition you apply some
thresholding so basically you put the
pixels that are almost black
blah you put them to zero or you make
them black
and then you just go back you invert the
initial function so
again you have you apply a function you
go in this domain
uh uh that you see at the center which
is the wavelet the complete
composition you threshold it and you
just go back
so i knew that you do that a number of
times
so that's the traditional approach and
what we did actually was actually
combining the traditional approach
what i just showed with the ai and
basically
what you think about deep learning nai
is basically the way i think at least
and i think it's a very powerful way to
think about this kind of stuff
is that a deep learning model is nothing
more than a functional
functional approximation uh
and here you actually you see our model
at least from uh from
from a very bird eye view
our model is is a composition of a
number of deep learning blocks
and each one of these deep learning
blocks looks like this
so you have your x in this case is the
image
you apply one function at the f that i
said before
another function the thresholding
function and
the inversion of that function again now
what we did is was instead of having the
hard-coded transformations
we learned them with a deep learning
approach
now what we did also was use a kind of
what is called in
the in the domain residual learning is a
very powerful way of
stabilizing the the learning plus uh
we computed some functions that were not
possible to compute with a learning
solution like with a deep learning
module
we compute them uh as an external input
and then we provide it as a as input now
all the model is fully trainable
and so that means uh also relating back
to the work here presented before
in general it's a great thing that the
nvidia and all the
two i2 kits are actually supporting
hybrid computations
that's really is pushing the boundary of
the research
uh because we can integrate let's say uh
fourier transforms into into the model
so now
um yeah so here to go a bit more into
the details uh
now it's becoming a bit technical i just
want to mention for those of you that
are actually uh working on the uh on the
on the field uh the f function so again
the sparsifying transform
the thresholding and the inversion are
actually
implemented like a similar of
a unit design so if you are
familiar with that it's basically an
architecture that
looks like this where basically the
first part corresponds to the inversion
and and then we have a uh going back
from the
uh from the image from this sparsified
space
and plus we have something that we added
uh which is this threshold
now okay this is maybe a bit technical
uh
but one thing that i that i would like
to mention is that actually
we achieved great results just by
sticking to very basic deep learning
operations
so in literals in literature nowadays
you are overwhelmed by a lot of
different architectures
a lot of different uh computations we're
by design stick
to very simple one because we knew that
we can control
and we can inject in a much bigger
framework and so that was a
very powerful idea and it works uh like
a charm
okay now i presented the uh the
architecture
for some of you it resonated better than
for others but
okay that's kind of the flavor but i
think uh
another thing that you see in the ai
literature is that people
tend to focus a lot on at least maybe
outside also the the
pure machine learning research community
is that people tend to focus a lot on
architecture and
try a lot of different architectures but
actually
one important point is actually the
definition of the loss function
because as i say um
the loss function so if a deep neural
network
is a uh or a deep learning model is a a
racing car the loss function is the is
the
is the driver and power is is nothing
without control
so you really need to have a right the
right loss function
to drive um to drive the
um your network and
in the collaboration with lmc we focus
on the exploration of
a lot of uh loss functions and
uh that was i mean i think this is
actually not all of them we
actually explore a bit more a lot of
combination of them
more of advanced one and more simple
simpler one but we really do a thorough
analysis
and the most important lesson there was
actually that these numbers
do not do not actually capture the real
true quality of the resulting images
so for us was extremely important not to
just validate them on numbers like
on these tables here where you see a lot
of different losses
with the corresponding let's say quality
metrics and we had
actually quite some of these quality
metrics uh
it's actually more important to just
generate the images
and just look at them to get the flavor
of uh
of the resulting image quality that was
really important we showed that to
radiologists
and and that was a super important
feedback that we got
um yeah i think in view of time i will
not
go too much in details in the in the one
that we that we have chosen
uh but yeah okay so it's it's called
multi scales as i am
and it's uh it's was designed to mimic
uh the perceptual uh uh
behavior the perceptual system of humans
in such a way that
uh artifacts at different scales are uh
um weighted equally so here on the right
you see uh for example an image with
different uh
um basically degradation different
frequencies
and basically a a number of people were
asked to
um to grade to find
uh which level of artifact the
it was the same so in this case the red
boxes
correspond to that and yeah so that's
really to
again the focus of putting the human in
the in the loop actually this is my
focus at
ue as well i'm really uh interested in
in in focusing our machine learning
model in such a way that can
help us directly and not just uh put
output a number that maybe is not
controlled and we cannot really rely on
and on top of that we actually adopted
an adapted
uh mixed approach because we for for
optimizations reasons is much easier
to uh achieve a better results
now that's that's the piece on the loss
function again is super important if you
if you're working machine learning
please
uh focus on the on it uh quite quite
substantially i i don't see it
too often around and but that's super
important
now about the training um
so again also another trend in that we
didn't follow
in machine learning is to okay we want
to have a model that
rules it all right so that one single
model works for everything uh
at the same time for the challenge we
observed that there were two very
different looking images
in the challenges and you can see them
here one let's say the
the bright one and the dark one
um so and they had different on the
sampling rate
uh different protocols which i just said
the bright and dark
uh they are called protocols and also
they are acquired with two different
systems
um now a way to train will be to train
for all of them so that we have a model
that works
for all of them which is feasible but in
the challenge we were
focused on the on getting the best
possible result
so what we did instead was to train one
single model that can
work for everything and then we fine
tune this model several times
to on the more specific subpopulations
so um again so we
took the model fine tune on the on the
different accelerations that we
were supposed to focus on and then for
the different scanners and different
output now this is again another
powerful concept
again i'm not i'm not giving the details
here but i in general
if you do machine learning that's a
powerful concept you can start from a
model that
works very well in general and then you
can make it
super optimized for some specific
working conditions
all right so that's kind of the the
overview of the of the
design philosophy loss function and
training strategy
let's uh let's have a look at some
results uh
because of course those are more
insightful
uh here you see uh on the left
actually the what we would get if we do
the traditional reconstruction
and you can see it's basically well
you hardly see actually a knee there on
the right you see the ground truth
while at the center you see the
reconstruction
now the reconstruction is is not optimal
this is something that by no means
is going to be using the clinical
practice but
if you compare with what we start with
it's really yeah it's really
day and night and we can achieve that
not in this case i have to say
partially because of the ai but the main
focus here
if you look also at our competitors was
really to to integrate this hybrid
computation
such that the data that we acquired are
actually dominating the ai part
again so this is really pushing the
boundary is not going to be used but if
we look at yeah
this is another example very extreme for
again a different uh for a very uh
challenging
reconstruction this one looks already a
slightly better again
will not be used on a
let's say the very uh tricky scans but
in general can can you open up new
application actually
um again this one this one actually
is a for an acceleration of four uh here
you can see a
bit better the results are actually
getting quite good at this point in time
you can see nicely also define uh
defined structure
at the center and uh yeah that's
that's rather good if we go to another
more
another acquisition that is less noisy
already with a high acceleration of
eight
uh the recon looks quite good this is
quite good and it
will can accelerate the reconstruction
up to a factor of eight
so reduce the time that you're spending
the scanner by a factor of eight
uh well if you reduce uh by a factor of
uh
we go to less than four basically you
can hardly tell
any difference between the uh the
reconstruction and the ground truth
which is yeah pretty good because we we
know that we can
directly have an impact on people
getting a scan and that brings me to the
the conclusions where we won and go on
the uh two most
challenging tracks um
improvement over the compressing
compressed sensing theory
uh with i think it's within reach uh
importance of designing the loss
function and evaluated with the
uh with people directly looking at it
and also the importance of
combining prior knowledge which is in
this case mr physics
but in general i mean every physically
inspired model
uh uh it's getting traction and i think
it's the future
so that's uh that's pretty it's pretty
cool demonstration of that i would say
this uh this challenge
and let me just conclude by saying that
i'm here presenting for the for the team
uh but yeah again the team was uh
extremely talented people uh it was a
very inspiring to work with them and
yeah that brings me to the end of the
talk and
uh and i'm happy to answer any question
yes thank you very much nikola for this
amazing talk so we do have a couple of
interesting questions
from the audience so to start with the
first
question from xtr um
well it's great to be in such a
competition from a team building
perspective
what do you think gave you the edge in
terms of profile of different people
inside the team for winning the
competition
i i like this so much uh actually so we
had
the main focus that when we built the
team was really to have
people with different but complementary
uh
skills so i'm purely let's say a machine
learning and data analysis uh
person actually when i started i had
very limited amount of knowledge
we had people deeply in dmr aside we
limited the
machine learning knowledge we had people
from lmc
without machine learning and without mr
knowledge but with the
uh with let's say the radiology side
they
they know what to look for and so really
the combination was the
like boosting the performance yeah
incredibly
okay cool super interesting and then
another question phone
and then nina will this be implemented
within the clinic
uh absolutely that's of course our uh
our goal so i mean the challenge was
good but for phillips in general
the main focus is on the uh on the
improving the the life of the of the
patients
so yeah of course that's the the angle
we have to see when we will
get there but yeah as a as a research
uh we always strive to uh to get to the
yeah yes
and then uh another question from act
here
do you have any intentions of uh posting
a
challenge on chaol yourself
sorry on
yeah actually the the no ourselves uh
not really but
there is a new challenge from uh from uh
uh
uh the organizers the nyu and and
and facebook they already organized the
second challenge
and actually they want in the future
also to
expand uh to uh the their data set
maybe it's funny to say that all the
first mri data was on
a data from our competitor with siemens
and so it was great actually to win on
their data and
and but of course we they are aiming
actually have a multi-vendor
data set in the future yes and then uh
was
the last uh question from my side
so he discussed it's really important to
involve the
radiologist in designing the loss
function
so how do you feel about the fact that
it might be
from a literature and academic
perspective
it might be an incentive to go for the
benchmarks that are out there just to
get your publications out there more
easily
well of course this might be a little
bit the opposite of
doing a new research and coming up with
your
own design loss function based on the
radiologist input
because it's kinda makes it from a
research perspective maybe a little bit
subjective on
exactly what kind of loss function you
choose based on
human input yeah yeah that's
uh i'm really passionate about this uh
what you can see is that the machine
learning community is super focused on
on the numbers they just want the
numbers sometimes i have collaborations
where people
just want to look at the the numbers
they never look at the the resulting
images
and i can understand that from a machine
learning point of view
uh i think really to have a
let's say from a practical point of view
uh
those that will really have an impact in
the field in general
but they really go beyond that they try
to understand
when the laws well let's say the metrics
are not really
fitting the task that we have to solve
because there is the this idea that the
metrics are everything but the metrics
are not
capturing the the the true meaning what
we really want to achieve
and one thing to say is that we didn't
encode the radiologist
uh as a metric we just uh
worked with our metrics and presented
the results
and then still use existing metrics but
we selected them based on the on the
human input our taste i'm not sure if
it's clear
it's a complicated topic yeah i think
it's quite
clear so you kind of try to bridge the
worlds in that sense still give them
metrics right
but as like a final call on both
radiologists to actually
have an open discussion on what the
right metrics will be in the first place
yeah correct and maybe another side note
uh in the challenge there were two
phases
uh in the first one uh the let's say the
top five were selected by
based on the metric and then uh the
final
winners were selected based on the under
ideologies input
and what you could see that in some of
the tracks actually uh the winners
of the radiologist's uh feedback uh were
actually not the winner in the
in the matrix so that's really a clear
demonstration of that
so would you consider having these kind
of contests
a good way of yeah bridging this gap
absolutely that's i think uh
uh absolutely yes